let me show you this tweet
we have this from will kane
wait till you see this he says the lies
never stop in the first tweet if you can
see it it's the independent it says kyle
rittenhouse cleared of murder after
shooting dead two black lives matter
protesters full story teenager who shot
three black men with a rifle found not
guilty on all charges sick absolutely
not true they have to know isn't it
crazy absolutely insane and i think i
said this last time that almost every
progressive i know which believe it or
not i have a lot of progressive friends
almost all of them were under the
misconception that the people who died
were black that they were innocent
protesters and even as of a few hours
ago i tweeted something positive about
ridden house i forget exactly what i
said but a lot of their replies were
from my more liberal supporters who were
like wait is this true that one of them
was a pedophile how do you not know that
at this point
it's because of this it teaches us just
how poorly people are getting themselves
involved in the details of this case but
everyone has an opinion oh yeah
everybody's got an opinion but almost no
one is actually taking the time to look
at the details of the case because
people would rather just be lied to by
the corporate media and i love that we
talked about how this is such a win for
the simple fact that it's such a loss
for corporate media yes yes i think it's
waking people up
this particular case so there's more uh
in will kane's tweet he also has
this tweet from the democratic
congressional campaign committee yeah
this is this is the organization that
helps give money to democrats running
for congress who's who and they said
it's disgusting and disturbing that
someone was able to carry a loaded
assault rifle into a protest against the
unjust killing of jacob blake first of
all there was no assault rifle
and a lot of people are like stop saying
you know what really bugs me is when the
gun to a people say there's no such
thing as an assault rifle stop there is
a select fire rifle that's typically
what it refers to and most people
understand that but
we have to use definitions properly the
left has assault rifle to mean rifle
it's meaningless yeah so i'm going to
use the the correct definition there was
not a single person with an assault
rifle but more importantly jacob blake's
not dead right exactly exactly wow yeah
he's partially paralyzed
and so they said unjust killing that's
the democrats putting out their message
they have no idea what's going on in
this world or they know and they're
willfully ignorant they corrected it
they corrected it after the fact saying
oopsie here's the corrected email they
have no idea what's going on but they're
so comfortable fanning the flames of
what's going on which is so sick because
people forget the contacts in which the
written house situation even happened it
was because buildings were on fire
people were being hurt the police were
standing down like vigilante justice is
only bound to pop up when that situation
arises like people have and i was
talking about this earlier i feel like
people have almost like blind spots when
it comes to remembering 2020. i think
there was some sort of collective trauma
that happened to people people forget
how bad it was it was terrible and
people were terrified can i show you
guys a story from the night in question
on august 25th 2020 when when all this
was going down in the chaos and the
riots and everything that happened we
have another story it's from the new
york post august 26th 2020.
this is um i'm assuming that this story
is about august 25th considering it was
published the following day but it may
have actually been from before uh and
and been what one of the things that
kyle rittenhouse saw so this will this
will be a sort of correction i'm not
entirely sure but i said before that i
thought videos like this
inspired the people who went out there
with guns
from the new york post
elderly man defending store during
kenosha riots has jaw broken i mean
that's the gist of the story i can't i
can't show you the images it's graphic
and horrifying an elderly man watching
his store be ransacked and burned to the
ground and he's got a fire extinguisher
spraying at the door and at people and
someone runs up and cracks him in the
side of that with a rock dropping him
his elderly man laying on the ground
disoriented unconscious bleeding from
the face and then some other people run
up and try and render aid i can't
imagine what it must be like for the
people of kenosha to know this happened
yeah and to have had this trial but i
will say
there are videos that have been going
around where people are filming random
cars and the car stopped and like hey
hey like what do you think about what
happened they're like kyle juan like
this is a good day and they're cheering
for me like he was defending himself the
people of kenosha i think know what it
means when people are destroying your
town and they know what went down that
night and they know who kyle was and i
mean that figuratively not literally
knew he was but they knew what kind of
what kind of kid he was and what kind of
town they had and i think the people of
kenosha overwhelmingly were in support
of him it was disproportionately
minorities as well that were harmed by
all of the fires and all the rioting and
the losers right
that's right it was uh it was a poor
multi-racial community and that's the
same thing that happened in ferguson yes
it's crazy isn't it kyle writtenhouse is
the worst white supremacist ever
just shoots white people yeah right
and that's and that's
the the narrative is just insane that
they persist i have friends i've lost
friends over this they don't resp
they're not responding to me i've had
friends for for years
and i see them posting about kyle
rittenhouse and they're saying really
awful things comparing him to charles
manson
and i sent a message and i'm just like
calm and passionately like you know hey
what's up
what's going on did you watch the trial
do you know what's happening and they
just ignore me out right what do you
think it is about this well i think what
happens is when i post something like
kyle rittenhouse is the clearest case of
self-defense i've ever seen and that's a
quote from destiny who was a left-wing
streamer but he's correct he was correct
the whole time he got in trouble twitch
just like banned him um from the from
the professional program whatever it's
called
i post things like that what do you
think happens then when i have friends
who are trapped in the matrix
and they hear from the independent a
white supremacist crossed state lines
with an assault rifle to hunt down or
kill black lives matter protesters they
see me post it was self-defense or
that written house should be not guilty
and they're thinking i can't believe my
good friend is now supporting overt
white supremacists who are murdering
people what's happened to this country
but they just don't know because they're
trapped in the matrix but i can't even
and this is this is where the problem is
politics flows in one direction i
message them like let's talk and they
say
no
i'm willing to say i need you to see the
truth but they don't want to do it they
like where they live they like the hate
yeah it's tough to shatter people out of
the matrix through text never really
works well they don't see anything else
but the corporate media so when you when
you have the same trash regurgitated to
you repeated after one lie and another
line another lie you build this huge
foundation that has absolutely no merit
in reality and it's being propagated not
just by the corporate media not just the
people who pull the strings of the
corporate media but also the puppets of
the the people who pull the strings of
course that's politicians like kamala
harris kamela harris just came out with
a statement about this entire situation
and she said quote
this verdict really speaks for itself as
many of you know i spent a majority of
my career working to make the justice
system more equitable and clearly there
is a lot more work to do and i'm like b
you put innocent people behind bars and
bailed out the rioters and bailed out
the writers yeah it not only bailed out
the rioter not only called for criminals
to be let out of jail but knew that she
had evidence that someone was innocent
and she still decided to vindictively
hold that person in jail for over two
years non-violent drug
offenses she put people behind bars
there's a mosaic collage right now with
all the black people she put in jail
that's great i i will not i will not sit
here and listen to you besmirch
kamala harris
she yeah
she did not just
for no reason keep people who are
innocent behind bars she needed them to
work as slaves to put out fire for a
dollar an hour kamala harris kept people
in prison be uh rej denying their parole
so that she could use them for cheap
labor to fight wildfires
that woman is beyond despicable that is
an atrocity to commit against another
human being
by the way luke is correct is it
confirmed that that was her intent or is
this just like kind of people are like
so assuming no evidence it's her intent
so uh it was someone in her office who
said it at first a lot of people were
saying she kept innocent people in
prison beyond you know she kept people
in prison beyond their term to use his
cheap labor the full story is people
were up for parole and her office's
position was do not grant them parole we
need slave labor to fight wildfires yeah
and there's so many instances there's
one there's an article in ely weekly
that's titled daniel larson's an
innocent man says federal judge so why
is he still in prison he was in prison
because of kamala harris saying i want a
clean pristine record most of these
state prosecutors are sociopaths who
rather have a clean victory whoever who
rather of course have have a win column
rather than do the right thing there's
so many innocent people that have been
thrown in jail because of overzealous
insane psychopathic state prosecutors
and i think there's a big argument to
make here about our current vice
president being one before with her
track record which is absolutely
atrocious but did she make this
statement while she was president for
two hours today when biden was getting
his butt played with or what happened
well biden also came out with kind of
contradicting statements so that
whatever he was doing whatever he got
done to him up whatever well also
probably maybe i don't know had some
kind of effect because he was
flip-flopping like crazy
they're really i i do want to do a
longer discussion that's because i have
some tweets about it but i just i want
to add to this um
there is something deeply wrong in this
country when
you have to agree with injustice
to placate one political faction
it should be clear kyle rittenhouse
acted in self-defense and we all knew it
we've had on the show seven witnesses
from from various moments on that night
some direct witnesses richie mcginnis
himself who is named in the complaint
who rendered a de rosenbaum has been on
this show more than once and many other
people who were there that night and
they told us what happened and they
showed us the video and we all said
looks like self-defense but now because
there are people who are lied to or just
don't care the president the vice
president aclu and all these
institutions say
well
we need the support so just lie to him
the verdict's only surprising if you've
only been watching the corporate media
spin but the reaction hasn't surprised
anybody
everyone knew that this was primed but i
mean that's
that's the problem though is that the
video of what transpired that night has
been available for over a year
and there are so many people that were
so comfortable having this opinion have
never watched it because if you do watch
it in my opinion you can't walk away
with any other determination other than
yeah this kid was defending himself bad
situation but he was defending himself i
mean you have anna kasparian of the
young turks over a year after it
happened finally saying oh yeah by the
way woke up today watched a video i
think he did nothing wrong it's like
really after a year of you slandering
him yep that but you just do them that's
what all of these networks do it's the
craziest thing that's why they're like
tim poole's right wing no the difference
between you and me is that i just read i
read and i fact check thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time